>> YES.
>> WOW.
>> "INSIDE THE NBA," THE STUDIO
SHOW.
>> AND THE HOLOGRAM.
>> THEN YOU.
>> ERNIE, WE'RE SO LUCKY AND
BLESSED TO HAVE YOU AS THE
LEADER OF OUR TEAM AND
GODFATHER.
I WANT TO THANK EVERY SINGLE
PERSON WHO WORKS HERE.
WE HAVE SOME AMAZING PEOPLE WHO
WORK HERE.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
PERSONALLY, WHO IS HERE AND WHO
IS NOT HERE.
BECAUSE OF COVID, WE KIND OF
GOT --
>> NOT EVERYBODY WHO IS NORMALLY
HERE IS IN THE BUILDING.
>> BUT SHOUT OUT JASON,
MICKEY --
>> ALL THE PRODUCERS.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT THE STAGE
MANAGER.
>> KEITH.
>> JEREMY LEVINE, TIM KILEY.
>> AUDIO ROB.
>> KENTUCKY SHAWN.
>> WHAT IS HIS NAME?
>> THANK YOU, I APPRECIATE THAT.
>> THANK YOU, DRAYMOND.
>> AND LET ME SHOUT OUT, TOO,
THE OTHER GUYS WHO WERE IN MY
CATEGORY.
SCOTT VAN PELT WAS IN THERE,
MIKE TIRICO IS IN THERE.
RACHEL NICHOLS.
>> WE LOVE YOU RACHEL.
>> RICH EISEN.
JUST AWESOME TO BE --
>> COULD YOU TAKE THIS MOMENT
TO, YOU KNOW, SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT RECEIVING THIS AWARD?
YOU DIDN'T -- IT'S NOT LIKE YOU
WERE ON STAGE.
CAN WE GIVE YOU TWO MINUTES TO
JUST DO WHAT YOU WANT?
>> I DON'T NEED TWO MINUTES.
BUT WHAT I SAID ON THE TELECAST
TONIGHT WAS, YOU KNOW, IT'S A
GET TO JOB THAT WE HAVE HERE.
WE GET TO DO WHAT WE LOVE.
I GET TO WORK WITH YOU GUYS,
WITH THAT BASEBALL CREW, YOU
KNOW, PEDRO MARTINEZ AND CURTIS
GRANDERSON AND JIMMY ROLLINS.
AND NIGHTS LIKE THIS, WHEN YOU
GET TO RECEIVE SOMETHING IN THE
COMPANY OF THOSE GUYS, THIS
COULD HAVE GONE TO ANYBODY IN
THERE.
>> NO, YOU GOT IT.
>> AND THEN YOU GET TO SAY,
HEY --
>> SCOTT VAN PELT.
>> VERY PROUD OF EVERYBODY IN
HERE, AND TO MY LOVELY WIFE,
THANKS FOR PUTTING UP WITH ME.
>> AND ERNIE, THIS IS FOR YOU.
I HAVE ONE MORE TRICK.
>> OH!
>> THAT IS FOR YOU.
A ROSE.
>> THAT'S EVEN MORE IMPRESSIVE
THAN WHAT YOU GAVE CHUCK.
>> COME ON, MAN.
>> YOU LIKED T